you know robert e lee he was the leader
of the confederate army it's a part of
our history that we had a civil war uh
well charlottesville virginia which
obviously a couple years ago there was
the incident in charlottesville with
actual white supremacists who were
chanting and marching through
charlottesville and it was all because
they were going to take down a statue of
robert e lee
and
now they are going to take down a statue
of robert e lee in charlottesville and
they're going to melt it and turn it
into a social justice thingamajig we've
got a quote here from the newspaper that
is now known as the new york times but
it's really not a newspaper but we went
with the new york times i'm trying to be
nice i'm trying to be you know give you
a plurality of opinions around here the
city council of charlottesville virginia
voted on tuesday to donate a statue of
robert e lee to an african-american
heritage center that plans to melt the
bronze monument the focus of a deadly
white nationalist rally in 2017 into
material for a new piece of public art
the four to zero vote by the council
followed years of debate over the fate
of the statue four years ago a plan to
remove the statute drew scores of white
nationalists to charlottesville for a
unite the right rally that led to
violence including the killing of a
counter-protester by an ohio man who
plowed a car into a crowd after taking
it down the city accepted proposals from
bidders who wanted the lee statue and a
nearby statue of stonewall jackson
another confederate general that was
also removed so okay so let's back up
because this is a this is a big thing
this was one of the key moments over the
last couple years charlottesville very
fine people on both sides
white supremacists like the whole thing
right it all boiled down over the last
couple years in some ways to this very
moment in charlottesville so what
they're going to do now is they're gonna
take that statue they're gonna melt it
they'll turn it into some social justice
thing i don't know a george floyd
memorial or okay whatever they're gonna
do now that's i suppose the city
council's choice and if that's what
they're gonna do that's what they're
gonna do now as i always say with these
statue removal stories it's like does
any of this make us more tolerant does
anyone feel that we are becoming a more
tolerant a more open society because of
any of this are we turning to our
neighbor and looking at that neighbor
and giving them the benefit of the doubt
because of any of this or is it making
us actually more polarized is it oddly
making everything more racist have we
unearthed some stuff that we had put
down for a long time i think the answer
to that is probably yes but the reason i
wanted to do this story is not so much
that they're going to melt this thing
and turn it into some weird social
justice statute that's just fine if so
they choose um but
this is the moment that really broke a
lot of people when you talk about
trump-breaking people and the media
lying about everything so now i'm going
to show you the video right after the
charlottesville incident this is donald
trump talking about the white
supremacists
talking about canceling historical
figures and talking about very fine
people on both sides and you just see
for yourself if this video is the way
that it's framed when you hear about
this on mainstream media but you also
had people that were
very fine people on both sides
you had people in that group excuse me
excuse me i saw the same pictures as you
did you had people in that group that
were there to protest the taking down of
to them a very very important statue and
the renaming of a park from robert e lee
to another name
george washington was a slave owner
was george washington a slave owner
so will george washington now lose his
status are we going to take down excuse
me are we going to take down are we
going to take down statues to george
white
how about thomas jefferson what do you
think of thomas jefferson you like him
okay good are we going to take down the
statue because he was a major slave
owner now we're going to take down his
statue
so you know what it's fine you're
changing history you're changing culture
and you had people and i'm not talking
about the neo-nazis and the white
nationalists because they should be
condemned totally
did you get the last three seconds of
that he absolutely and his words totally
condemns the neo-nazis and the white
supremacists when he's talking about
very fine people on both sides he is
talking about very fine people on both
sides of whether you should take down
these statues because if you take down a
robert e lee statue
as he points out well then you're going
to have to take down george washington
statues and you're going to have to take
down thomas jefferson statues which of
course that is what the woke
progressives are coming to do now what's
interesting about that clip and i know
you guys know this because you watch
this show and you're not brainwashed you
know npc blue check buffoons um
he did do that and it's been debunked a
gajillion times but most people don't
know that most people don't know that
right after he said very fine people on
both sides which became a rallying cry
for the left in mainstream media that
donald trump
is is a racist and a white supremacist
even though he
condemned them just seconds later which
they never show that became a rallying
card what most people don't know is that
moment of trump right there
that is why joe biden said he was
running for president so now we're going
to show you a minute of joe biden's
campaign launch video and this is
actually quite extraordinary i wish
other people in mainstream media would
cover this sort of thing because joe
biden decided to run for president
because of charlottesville that's
exactly what he said and this is a
minute of his campaign ad take a look
it was there on august of 2017 we saw
klansmen and white supremacists and
neo-nazis come out in the open
[Music]
they're crazed faces
illuminated by torches veins bulging and
burying the fangs of racism
chanting the same anti-semitic bile hurt
across europe in the 30s
and they were met by a courageous group
of americans
in a violent clash ensued
and a brave young woman lost her life
and that's when we heard the words of
the present united states that stunned
the world and shocked the conscience of
this nation
he said there were quote
some very fine people on both sides
very fine people on both sides
you see what he did right there
you see what he did so just know that
joe biden in his campaign launch video
where he talks about the reason that he
got back into politics after stepping
away for four years was because trump
was racist
trump was basically a white supremacist
trump did not condemn white supremacists
and neo-nazis and i just show you the
video that he did i don't even mean to
make this all about trump
but this is what it's all about we are
being fed lies
and lies and lies and more lies and
until people are woken up from those
lies it is just
going to
continue it just ain't gonna stop so joe
biden launched his campaign on a lie
are you a biden supporter may want to
think about that may want to think about
that